I
or self consciousness has not yet
attained this happy state of being the
ethical substance the spirit of a people
for having turned back from its role of
observer spirit at first is not yet as
such realized through itself it is
established only as an inner essence or
as an abstraction in other words spirit
is at first immediate but existing
immediately it is separate and
individual it is the practical
consciousness which steps into its world
which it finds already given with the
aim of duplicating itself in this
distinct form of something separate and
individual of producing itself as this
individual as this existent counterpart
of itself and of becoming conscious of
this unity of its own actuality with the
objective being of the world self
consciousness has the certainty of this
unity it holds that the unity is
implicitly already present or that this
agreement of itself with thing hood
already exists and has only to become so
for it through its own agency or that
the production of that unity is equally
the finding of it since this unity means
happiness the individual is sent out
into the world by his own spirit to seek
his happiness
you'll notice that paragraph 356 begins
and ends with the same major
consideration that of happiness and
Hagel is going to be charting out not an
ethics but the dialectical development
and successes and failures of a number
of different positions in in ethics or
if you prefer different kinds of
morality lived moral theory although he
will make a distinction between ethics
and morality as we'll see happiness is
the term that's coming up here at the
very beginning of this in terms of the
happy state glooog lika all right
condition or state that that was talked
about in the last paragraph and it's
going to end with Hagel invoking
happiness as what it is that is
fundamentally driving what is
fundamentally drawing the the
self-consciousness the subject the human
being on and and you might be tempted to
read into this if you know something
about moral theory various forms of what
we call you diamond ism which is moral
theories that Center themselves around
conceptions of happiness so this would
include such moral theories as those of
ancient virtue ethicists like Plato and
Aristotle some people consider the
Stoics to be you dymonus of a certain
type although I think there's a good
argument against considering them to be
fundamentally that way the epicurean
hedonist tradition definitely fits into
that as well and many of the conceptions
that we have in modernity some of which
Hagel is going to chart out and examine
this that is if they don't exist in
ancient and medieval times at all but
they assume a certain prominence in in
modernity like this law of the heart
is going to chart out those all have to
do with this conception of happiness as
well so it might be tempting to read
into this something like you know
Aristotle saying well everybody really
desire is happiness or Thomas Aquinas
saying that but that we misconceived
most of us what the nature or the the
guys or the shape of happiness trulia so
some of us think it to be physical
pleasure and others think it to be honor
or social status or something along
those lines when we'd really understand
it's virtuous activity or contemplation
or being with God or whatever and what
hegel is driving at here is some of what
gets left out in those thumbnail
sketches of Aristotle and Thomas Aquinas
because that's not their full position
either happiness would be the full
realization of the human being as human
being and so that requires us to think
of a think out and think about what that
realization would be generally from a
standpoint where we don't actually enjoy
that realization so all of that said by
way of preface Hagel says the
self-consciousness has not attained this
happy state of being the ethical
substance the spirit of a people why
because having turned back from its role
of observer spirit at first the role of
observer was in the previous entire
section spirit at first is not yet as
such realized through itself it hasn't
fully come to terms with it that's to be
expected we're in the process of the
development here right so what is it
done he says it's established only as an
inner essence or as an abstraction so we
got to this point in the previous
paragraph swear the ethical substance
was being seen the substance being the
the mores the the entire life of a
people a folk a community was seen as
being abstract and in a certain sense
10 full but also content less it didn't
have essence to it anymore so he says in
other words spirit is immediate but
existing immediately it is separate and
individual now does this mean that
there's only one individual no there's a
number of individuals that spirit is now
diversifying itself we might say into
almost as if when we talk about you know
if you're a smart investor you diversify
your portfolio don't you don't put all
your proverbial eggs into one basket
spirit is becoming all of these
individuals who themselves are part of
the larger framework of society but also
have the possibility of being able to
truly see themselves as individuals
insofar as they do they wind up being
estranged from that ethical substance
that we talked about and needing to find
themselves that's what he's talking
about here so he says it's the practical
practice consciousness which steps into
the world or you know takes a step ein
threaten into the world which is already
given as he says or rather the world as
practical consciousness finds it for
gefunden de right the world that it's
it's finding the world that's there for
it and that's a world that's already got
all sorts of history and you know
various hierarchies of status and
perhaps opposition's it's stepping into
a world that is concrete not merely
abstract and what happens then now
here's where it gets really really
interesting Hagel says it has the aim of
duplicating itself in this distinct form
of something separate and individual now
what does that mean so to begin with is
duplicating for dole Belinda referred
opal right Zuzu for dull boom that's
what it's the the German actually reads
so it steps into this world for
that purpose of duplicating itself now
why does it have to duplicate itself
it's already in the world it already
exists well in order for it to be able
to understand itself in order for it to
be able to grasp itself it has to
duplicate itself this doesn't mean that
it creates a clone or that it's staring
in the mirror all the time another way
of thinking about this is it is
searching for its identity in no longer
you know well what's my social status or
something like that's something that's
merely given to it but in something that
it itself produces through its own
activity now this activity could be
enjoyment as it's going to be with
pleasure it could be in action itself is
in the law of the heart coming up or in
the quest for virtue it could be in a
number of other things including in
recognizing and respecting others all of
these are possibilities for the
individual spirit that is attempting or
the individual mind that is duplicating
itself as a truly separate individual so
he goes on he says some really
interesting things here he says it has
to take on this distinct form of
something separate and individual
producing itself as this individual as
the this existent counterpart of itself
and of becoming conscious of this unity
of its own actuality with the objective
being of the world so practical
consciousness is aiming at a unity in
duplicating itself it's not duplicating
itself so that it can create another
itself which would go off and maybe do
all the housework or you know do the
boring taxes or go to go take the stupid
classes or whatever it's duplicating
itself in the world in how it can see
itself and
remains a unity with itself even in that
duplication so he says self
consciousness has the certainty of his
unity and this is a unity not only with
the with itself with what it is created
of itself but also with the world to a
certain extent the way Hagel's talking
about it here so he goes on and he says
self consciousness has the certainty of
this unity it holds that the unity is
implicitly already present or this
agreement of itself with thing hood
being able to objectify itself being
able say I am this guy who chalks up the
chalkboard right for example already
exists this agreement already exists and
has only to become so for it through its
own agency I Know Who I am I just
alright it on the chalkboard I'll show
you I'll show myself and showing you I
show myself what I am in this case a man
explaining hagel because that's part of
his identity is the practical conscience
is that as an example right the guy who
puts on a tie a certain way and so he
goes on and he says the production of
that unity is equally the finding of it
now this unity this unity means
happiness here's where it gets very
interesting and also harkens back to if
not Aristotle certainly Aquinas and
other thinkers where what makes us truly
happy is not just a sort of fulfillment
of ourselves but this sense of finding
what is truly appropriate to us what we
really are that's this unity that isn't
just a mere fusion but is an identity
and difference or a commonality a
sharing a communion so Hagel goes on
since this unity means happiness the
individual is sent out into the world by
his own spirits I his own Geist to seek
his own happiness now notice what that
last line is saying this is not yet a
possession happiness this is what is
desired this is what we're seeking this
is the vac the end that he's going to
talk about in so many of the paragraphs
yet to come
if then for us the truth of this
rational self consciousness is the
ethical substance here for that
self-consciousness it is the beginning
of its ethical experience of the world
insofar as it has not yet become the
ethical substance this movement presses
forward to it and what is superseded in
the movement are the individual moments
which for self-consciousness are valid
in their isolation they have the form of
an immediate will or natural impulse
which obtains its satisfaction which is
itself the content of a fresh impulse if
however self-consciousness has lost the
happiness of being in the substance
these natural impulses are bound up with
an awareness that their goal is the true
character and essential nature of
self-consciousness the ethical substance
has sunk to the level of a predicate
devoid of self who's living subjects are
individuals who themselves have to
provide the filling for their
universality and to fulfill their
essential nature through their own
efforts taken in the former sense then
those forms are the coming to be of the
ethical substance and precede it in the
latter they succeed it and reveal to
self-consciousness what it's ethical
nature is in the former case the
immediacy or rawness of the impulses
gets lost in the process of getting to
know what their truth is and their
content takes on a higher floor in the
latter case what is lost is the false
idea of the consciousness which places
it's essential nature in those impulses
in the former case the goal they attain
is the ethical substance well in the
latter it is the consciousness of that
substance a consciousness which knows
the substance to be its own essence and
to that extent this process would be the
coming into existence of morality of a
higher form than the ethical substance
but these forms at the same time
constitute only one side of morality
entry into existence that namely which
belongs to being for self or in which
consciousness sets aside its ends not
the side where morality arises from the
ethical substance itself since these
moments cannot as yet carry the
significance of
being made into ends opposed to the lost
ethical order they signify here it is
true no more than what they immediately
are and the goal which they strive to
attain is the ethical substance but
since in our own times that form of
these moments is more familiar in which
they appear after consciousness has lost
its ethical life and in the search for
it repeats these forms they may be
represented more in terms of this sort
running throughout paragraph 357 are a
number of distinctions or if you like
the economies of perspective where Hagel
is going to play one thing off of
another thing as two different ways of
looking at the same matter that are
fundamentally different from each other
there's there's an antithesis there that
he's sketching out and the first one is
between the viewpoint for us right thus
the observer the the person who's
following along in the phenomenology who
has some idea of where they're going and
some remembrance of where we've been for
us he says the truth of rational self
consciousness is the ethical substance
we've already discussed that but that's
not the case for the self-consciousness
he says for that self-consciousness the
one that we're observing the one that
we're following out its its narrative
and its progression and its development
he says it is the beginning of its
ethical experience of the world it's a
very interesting thing to say
particularly given where we're going in
the next oh you know three subchapters
I'm not sure exactly how many paragraphs
we have in there these are not
particularly long subchapters but we're
looking at about another here we go up
to 393 so we're talking about another 40
paragraphs or so give or take all of
that is going to be charting out this
ethical experience of the world this
growing in understanding its own ethical
position its own successes in its own
failures so let's follow along he says
insofar as it has not yet become the
optical substance right which is what
it's driving for
although there's going to be a little
twist along hey is there great to see
insofar as it does not yet become the
ethical substance this movement presses
forward to that it's something that we
are desiring this ethical substance is
you might say the lost object that we're
continually searching for once we've
left that happy state of innocence we
want to bring things back together again
and be good again be right again and
that's what we're we're seeking for
that's what the individual consciousness
is seeking for in its own development
through these dialectics so he says what
is superseded what is alcohol but in the
movement are the individual moments
which for self-consciousness are valid
in their isolation so we start out with
these individual moments so we could put
a whole plurality of them there what is
he talking about an individual
consciousness a person a human being so
he says they have the form of an
immediate will an unmediated on mental
bar and hear the word for will in this
case is not villa it's Volant it's this
is the verb it's a willing of volition
you might say or a natural impulse and
now through three right tree just means
like a drive I'm going to talk about
somebody having drives that are that are
in telling them towards something right
that's that's a tree and Hagel says
there's two things going on here he says
on the one hand these natural impulses
are about you know trying to obtain
their satisfaction we have these drives
or this this willingness choosing is
doing and it wants satisfaction so you
don't think for example about when
you're a kid and you get some candy and
candy sweet and when you're a kid
sweetness is pretty great isn't it and
you want some more candy here in the
States we have Halloween and as I'm
shooting this that's coming up later
this month I think back to when I was a
kid
going around trick-or-treating there was
all the fun and the pageantry in
costumes and you get to eat a little bit
of candy along the way and you know
there'd be all the doing things let me
get home and you pour all that candy out
of your bag or your pumpkin or whatever
else you are collecting it in maybe a
pillowcase and then you start looking at
the candy and then you start gobbling it
up right and your parents would say oh I
can't eat it all tonight but you'd
probably do do quite a good job and as
we say putting a hurt on that pile of
candy why well because you have a you
have a tree you have a natural impulse
to cram your mouth full of sweet stuff
now what happens when you do that
satisfying thing you know the
satisfaction wears off right and you get
a bit older you discover sexuality you
know same sort of progression right
there's a lot of pleasure to be had in
sexuality for a little while this and
then you know it leaves wanting to do
some more back in in its place and we
can say the same thing with desire after
desire after desire right and people
sometimes get caught up in that this
endless progression I mean that that's
what happens in in drug addiction but
also in other forms of you know desire
that that turns into kind of an endless
cycle so Hagel says that that this is
something that you know we do have
happen we have this natural impulse it
obtains its satisfaction and then it's
satisfaction provides the content of a
fresh impulse now what he says after
that is there's another possibility if
however self-consciousness has lost the
happiness of being in the substance the
happiness the gluc the enjoyment of
being in the ethical substance of
knowing where you fit in to your society
with its norms and its laws and your
proper place right if it's lost this
happiness these natural impulses are
bound up with an awareness that their
goal is the true character an essential
nature
of self-consciousness is no this is
interesting could it just be that
sometimes people mistake is well the
true nature and essential nature of
self-consciousness is just to get off or
to cram your face full of candy as often
as you can or to make a ton of money and
die with it at the end that's even you
know serves sattar idea of happiness but
really what it is is it's something that
lies beyond mere satisfaction all right
there's a goal let's vac hagel by the
way in this passage Miller is
translating it's back in two different
ways goal is one way that you can
translate it makes perfect sense another
way that he's translating it is with the
word end and you know when we talk about
making something into an end deciding on
that that's really synonymous with with
goal so so don't get too caught up on
the distinction of language there
because it's really not a distinction in
the German so he goes on and he says the
ethical substance is sunk to the level
of a predicate devoid of self who's
living subjects are individuals which
themselves have to provide the filling
for their universality they have to
decide what counts as the universal for
themselves in the course of their own
experience it may be that pleasure as
we're going to see in the first
dialectic is what we we strive for or it
might be a sort of satisfaction in
oneself as a good person not something
ethics talks an awful lot about but
Hagel realizes how important how driving
that is for us human beings or perhaps
it's in some transcendent conception of
virtue that them transcended through our
own individuality at least so he goes on
and he says they have to fulfill their
essential nature through their own
efforts and then now here come a lot of
dichotomies taken in the former sense
those forms are the coming to be of the
ethical substance and precede it and the
forms Percy
ethical substance in the ladder they
succeeded and revealed to self
consciousness what its essential nature
is so there's there's two sides that we
can look at here so again in the former
case the immediacy or rawness of the
impulses gets lost in the process of
getting to know what their truth is and
their content takes a higher form this
is a bit more important when we're
following out something that we think is
going to make us happy that is going to
be our goal when we're looking at it
carefully we start to learn more about
it but we lose that immediacy of the
charge that it gives us right that's
good we're learning more about ourselves
in the process I figure out you know
something about the sweetness that I
enjoy eating and I figure out that it's
not just that but there's something else
going on there and now i'm no longer
quite attending to the sensuousness of
the sweetness and i'm paying more
attention to the whole process i can
then raise it to a higher level he goes
on and he says in the latter case what
is lost is the false idea of the
consciousness which places its essential
nature in those impulses again in the
former case the goal they attain is the
ethical substance so we're driving at in
the latter it's the consciousness of
that substance a consciousness which
knows the substance to be its own
essence there's this reconciliation of
what has been alienated the individual
from the ethical substance and he says
to the extent this process would be the
coming into existence of a morality
amirali tete in german something that is
a higher state of existence or a higher
gestalt than mere ethical substance mere
following what the people do in your
country right merely replicating the
norms within yourself than transmitting
them to others
once we begin thinking about what we
ought to do what's good and what's bad
what's right and what's wrong what's
better and what's worse we start to trip
we start to step onto the path of
morality of something that is more
self-conscious something that's more of
our nature a Heinkel doesn't want to
split these apart forever he says that
morality would be a higher form than the
ethical substances but these forms at
the same time constitute only one side
of morality is entry into existence that
namely which belongs to being for self
consciousness or in which consciousness
sets aside its ends its original ends
its original goals its original zeca
that are being provided to it by the
ethical substance right it sets asides
it sends not the side where morality
arises from the ethical substance itself
the morality and ethical substance or
the ethical the zit lika are not
necessarily opposed to each other but
they often are at certain moments in
history and for certain individuals so
he goes on and he says since these
moments at this point in development
cannot as yet carry the significance of
being made into ends opposed to the lost
ethical order notice you can't get this
and you also can't get this not yet not
at this point that's what we're about to
to try to do in these these dialectics
he says since you don't have either of
these they signify here no more than
what they immediately are and the goal
which they strive to attain is the
ethical substance but since in our own
in our times that form of these moments
is more familiar in which they appear
after consciousness has lost its ethical
life and in the search for it repeats
these forms they may be represented more
in terms of this sort now what are the
terms of this sort well we're about to
get to these these are going to be these
three dialectical movements that
Eagle is essentially prioritizing and
he's doing that from the standpoint of
people who in the modern era have become
estranged from their ethical substance
from there you know the what was being
provided to them by the the life of
their their people their nation their
folk so that's going to be described in
the you know next 30 odd paragraphs to
come but also in the next two paragraphs
that are rounding out this introductory
section